When advertising began in a significant way in the [early] 19th century
It was a relatively straightforward business. It showed you a product told you what it did where you could get it and what it cost
Then in 1960s America a remarkable new way of advertising emerged
Led by Luminaries of Madison Avenue Like William Bernbach
David ogilvy and Mary Wells lawrence in their work for brands like Soa vests and life cereal
Adverts cease to be in a narrow sense about the things that they were selling
The focus of an ad might ostensibly be on a car
But our attention was also being directed at the harmonious handsome couple holding hands beside it
It might unsurfaced be in adverted out soap
But the true emphasis was on the state of calm that accompanied the washing
It might be whiskey one was being invited to drink
But it was the attitude of resoluteness and resilience on display that provided the compelling focal point
Madison Avenue had made an extraordinary discovery however appealing a product might be there were many other things
That were likely to be even more appealing to customers and by in twining their products with these ingredients
Sales could be transformed
[Patek] [Phillipe] is one of the giants of the global watchmaking industry
Since 1996 they've been running a very distinctive series of adverts featuring parents and children
It's almost impossible not to have glimpse one somewhere in one example a father and son are hanging out together in scenes
Which tenderly evoke filial and paternal loyalty in love we can imagine the boy will grow up confident and independent
It also respectful and warm the advert understands our deepest hopes around our children
It's moving because what it depicts is so hard to find in real life
We're often brought to tears not so much by what we have as by what we long [for] but cannot reach
Father-son relationships are dependably problematic, but in the world of patek phillipe
We glimpse a kind of psychological?
Paradise we can turn to Calvin Klein the couple seemed like they might have been together a while
They may have a couple of children, and they're in it [for] the long term [the] perfume is called eternity
But their passion is still so intense they have sex. Maybe a couple of times a day often in unusual locations
Calvin Klein knows all about what we really want in relationships
It's brilliantly latched on to our deepest and at the same time our most elusive [in] a long house
Adverts wouldn't work
If they didn't operate with a very good understanding of what [our] real needs are
What we truly require to be happy their emotional pull is based on knowingness [eerily]
Well as they recognize we are creatures who hunger for good family relationships
Connections with others a sense of freedom and joy a promise of self-development
Dignity calm and the feeling that we're respected yet armed with this knowledge
They and the Corporation's who bankroll them are unwittingly somewhat cruel to us
For while they excite us with reminders of our buried longings. They cannot do anything wholehearted about quenching them
Adverts may want to sell us things but incommensurate things in relation to the hopes they've aroused
Calvin Klein makes lovely Cologne Patek Phillipe swatches are extremely reliable in beautiful agents of timekeeping
But these items cannot by themselves help us secure. The goods are unconscious believed were on offer
the real crisis of capitalism is the product development lags so far behind the best insights of
advertising since the [1960's]
Advertising has worked out just how much we need help with the true challenges of life
Its fathomed how deeply we want to have better careers
stronger relationships greater confidence in most adverts the pain and the hope of our lives have been superbly
Identified but the products are almost comically at odds with the problems at hand
Advertisers are hardly to blame. They are in fact the victims of an extraordinary oblem of Modern capitalism
While we have so many complex needs we have nothing better to offer ourselves in the face of our troubles
Then perhaps a slightly more accurate chronometer or a more subtly blended perfume
business needs to get more ambitious in the creation of new kinds of
Products in their own way as [strange-sounding] today as a wristwatch would have struck observers in 1500
We need the drive of commerce to get behind filling the world in our lives with goods that really can help us to thrive
Flourish find contentment and manage our relationships well to trace the future shape of capitalism
We only have to think of all the needs we [have] that currently lie outside [of] [commerce]
We need help in forming cohesive interesting benevolent communities. We need help in bringing up children
We need help in calming down at Key moments
We require immense assistance in discovering our real talents in the workplace
[our] higher needs are not
Trivial or minor once
Insignificant things we could easily survive without they are in many ways central to our lives
We've simply accepted without adequate protest that there is nothing business could sell us to address them we don't know today quite
What the businesses of the [future] will look like just as half a century ago?
No one could describe the corporate essence of the current large technology companies, but [we] can know the direction
We need to head [to] one where the drive and inventiveness of capitalism tackles the higher deeper problems of life
Advertising has at least done as the great service at hinting at the future shape of the economy it already
Trades on all the right ingredients
The challenge now is to narrow the Gap between the fantasies being offered and what businesses should be able to sell us
you